one of the toughest coronavirus
lockdowns in asia is to be eased even
further Hong Kong allowed many people to
return to work on Monday and is now
lifting other restrictions a lockdown
was imposed in March a month after
travel from China was stopped there have
been no new local copy 19 infections
reported for two weeks now Hong Kong's
chief executive Carrie Lam announced at
cinemas and bars can reopen later this
week and secondary schools will return
later this month
let's bring in Katrina you in Beijing
forests I imagine relief Katrina for the
people in Hong Kong tell us more about
the new measures announced by Kerala
that's right a lot of relief well she
attended a press conference and the
theme of this was hope on the horizon
and it was very aptly named as the
government and Carrie Lam said that they
were very confident that the corona
virus outbreak in Hong Kong was under
control enough to ease some of these
very strict measures that have been in
place for weeks most importantly
starting on Friday people aren't going
to be able to gather in public in groups
of up to 8 people now that's double the
previous maximum of four people and many
keep businesses key entertainment
businesses will also be allowed to open
so that includes cinemas and theaters it
includes gyms and also beauty salons
also key was the announcement that some
schools are also going to be able to
finally reopen now they're not all going
to open at once they're going to be
opened in batches starting with the
older high school students they're going
to start to be able to go to class from
May 27 with younger high school students
and primary school students who are able
to start class from the beginning of
June
now this has come after the government
has seen dwindling coronavirus cases for
some weeks now in an end in the last 16
days there were no new local
transmissions there have been some
imported cases but there have been very
few single digits and the government is
confident that the measures in place are
enough to keep tabs on those but still
Hong Kong not completely out of the
woods yet one thing that was announced
is that the government will
Tribute reusable masks to every Hong
Kong citizen and they're expected to
wear those when they're out and about
and some businesses will remain shut for
at least another two weeks and that
includes nightclubs karaoke bars as well
as saunas and bath houses thank you for
that update Katrina you live there from
Beijing